david good to see you man how are you
thanks good how you doing carlos
good i'm not going to lie there's a part
of me that really wanted to
see you pop up and zoom in that red
guardian
like that would have made the entire
game
i would love that too can you tell
disney that i want to do that
so much yes i would love to do that too
man i'd love to wear it all the time
it's a great list i'm thinking like what
a great halloween costume
for a lot of us out there that don't
necessarily want to like maybe
do do all the sit-ups and maybe do all
that no you don't have to go to the gym
man it's great red guardians the best
cosplay you can do because you can eat
burgers and donuts and
still look great i'm curious you know
he's he's a great uh comedic character
in the film you bring so much to this
um was he always conceived that way like
all his great one-liners all that great
humor was that all on the page or was
that sorted out while you were filming
i mean he was definitely conceived as
this uh you know
he did he was he's a silly character in
a sense that he
um he has a lot of desperation a lot of
need uh but also there's
pathos there i mean i think he does feel
genuine remorse and guilt stuff like
that
but as we were shooting and as we went
along the dynamics changed and we
put in a lot of uh you know there's a
lot of improv in the movie
um i was really interested in his you
know relationship
to politics in certain ways uh to the
politics of like the other mcu
characters as well
and also in terms of his in rachel's
relationship that was more developed
as we went along and you know um
everything gets enlivened by the people
that
come into it with their particular
talents but
a lot of it was on the page i mean he
was written very well
yeah you know he someone who i read the
stories that had red guardian in them
as well like the avengers story is more
on that and i think it's really great
those mentions of like the glory days
like fighting captain america like
that's awesome
i know that he tells those stories but
for you when you're thinking about this
character did those actually happen in
his actual life
i mean that's a funny idea
i think to a certain degree and i don't
say this with derision
i think to a certain degree he is
psychotic so
what he believes happens
and whether or not it happened in
reality in his mind it very much
happened there are people called
confabulators
there's a whole psychiatric visible rock
confabulation which is just
people that sort of say things that
factually are wrong but they genuinely
believe them so much
that it doesn't matter the facts don't
actually matter it's their experience of
it
um and you know i think for
alexi a lot of that is the case i mean i
think that he
he lives in a world of his own
so it really was unimportant in terms of
playing him whether or not they happened
for me
they happened i mean for him the reality
is the reality so i just went with that
it would be interesting if there were
flies on the wall in those situations
because there is even a prison at one
point somebody
calls him out on a certain technical
thing in the story um
so i yeah i don't know how much of it is
real how much of it is fabricated but
for me playing the character all of it
was very very real and very important
that's awesome i would love to see him
back i love this character i want to see
him back in something else david
congratulations man thank you so much
this time thanks man